olaf scholz ganz ähnlich wie ein
mediziner muss auch die politik
natürlich entscheiden welchem
unternehmen beispielsweise man zuerst
hilft wem wird die politik welchen
firmen welchen branchen wird die politik
zuerst helfen und ist dann noch geld für
alle da gott sei dank haben wir diese
schwierige entscheidung nicht zu treffen
schlichtweg weil wir genug geld haben
wir können allen helfen und wir werden
es auch
und wenn die ökonomen tatsächlich auch
von der bundesregierung noch
weitreichendere maßnahmen gefordert
haben die fünf wirtschaftsweisen und
sich beispielsweise auch wünschen dass
es beteiligungen des bundes zeitweise an
firmen gibt ist das für sie vorstellbar
für mich ist das vorstellbare steht
jetzt nicht an aber das kann passieren
wenn die dinge sich lange so weiter
entwickeln und aus meiner sicht ist das
etwas wo die man überhaupt nicht
zurückscheuen muss wenn sie die
vorschläge die uns die ökonomen die wir
eben im bild gesehen haben diesen
mittwoch gemacht haben anschauen und die
vergleich mit dem was ich morgen
zusammen mit meinem kollegen altmaier
vorstellen werde dann werden sie sehen
hohe deckung übereinstimmung auch in der
großen koalition das ist ja schon mal
gut zu wissen zwischen wirtschafts- und
erlernt das ist jetzt nicht der
situation in der die bürgerinnen bürger
vor allem wissen müssen möchten wer sich
mit wem streitet und wenn sie sich nicht
streiten um so besser vor müller was
brauchen die betriebe jetzt am
allermeisten
die kleinen und die großen wir haben ja
das muss man noch mal verstehen sowohl
ein nachfrageproblem als auch ein
angebotsproblem sie haben china erwähnt
und ich will es auch in das verhältnis
jetzt noch sagen dieser virus wird uns
lange beschäftigen und deshalb wird auch
die wirtschaft lange mit den folgen der
jetzigen situation beschäftigt sein und
wir brauchen kurz mittel und
langfristige maßnahmen die dann auch
wirken
und deshalb ist es völlig richtig was
aktuell diskutiert wird kurzarbeitergeld
seien wichtiger punkt die
liquiditätshilfen und viele andere
punkte mehr
darling konkrete maßnahme und
erwartungen auch auf dem tisch die
fixkosten fristen die unternehmen jetzt
auf gerade die kleinen mittelständler
kommen eventuell liquiditätsprobleme
insolvenzen drohen und deshalb sind die
maßnahmen wie steuerstundungen viele
andere dinge jetzt wirklich wichtige
punkte in einem nächsten schritt werden
wir dann überlegen müssen wie bringen
wir die wirtschaft wieder auf den weg
wie können wir wieder nachfrage zum
beispiel ankurbeln das kurzarbeitergeld
für zu etwa 60 prozent des netzes ist
eine gute und eine starke aussage aber
noch nicht 100 prozent das heißt wann
springt welche nachfrage in welchen
branchen wieder an auch da werden wir
dann gezielt überlegen müssen und
langfristig ich habe am anfang gesagt
ist gerade in den verschiedenen branchen
großen transformation schritten es
müssen milliarden investiert werden
jetzt zum ambitionierte veränderungen
auch von strukturen zu machen
sie haben das thema klimaschutz gebracht
ein ganz wesentliches ziel was man
angehen ist und da werden wir natürlich
auch langfristig überlegen müssen können
wir belastungsmoratorium für die
wirtschaft diskutieren welche ziele sind
realistisch die müssen wir dort vorgehen
aber ich glaube wirklich in schritten
maßvoll wie ich das eben bei anderen
punkten gesagt haben so muss jetzt auch
hier für die wirtschaft und egal ob
klein oder groß es gibt verschiedene
probleme die dort sind
liquiditätsprobleme können auch große
unternehmen treffen wir haben erlebt was
heute an den börsen los war und deshalb
müssen wir da auch wirklich
zielgerichtet agieren noch mal die frage
an die finanzfachfrau irgendwann wird
sich die wirtschaft wieder erholen frau
alla
aber werden bestimmte kleine und große
firmen dann nicht mehr am markt sein
also ich wäre grundsätzlich so ein
bisschen vorsichtig allzu pessimistisch
zu sein also ich würde da schon für ein
bisschen optimismus auch plädieren
wollen weil wir haben es mit trifft alle
es trifft alle aber unser augenmerk
richtet sich auch in der
berichterstattung schon sehr stark auf
die branchen die es besonders hart
trifft es gibt aber noch viele andere
branchen die die schäden durch die
korona krise auch ganz gut wegstecken
können also es ist natürlich richtig die
branche zu unterstützen die die hilfe
brauchen wenn es mitunter ja auch sehr
große branchen sind die luftfahrt die
reisebranche und so weiter auch die
automobilbranche aber ich erwarte
eigentlich keine große rest also als
junior
da bleib ich und da würde ich mich schon
in der überwiegenden meinung der
ökonomen anschließen die sagen dass es
im ersten halbjahr ist mit einer
rezession zu rechnen
das liegt einfach daran dass wir ein
schwaches wirtschaftswachstum hatten und
deswegen auch sehr angreifbar sind
und selbst im zweiten halbjahr also über
das gesamte jahr könnten wir in eine
rezession rutschen
herr professor thorsten wenn die
chinesen und das hören wir aus peking
jetzt festlegen dass das virus gekämpft
ist und dass man jetzt die wirtschaft
wieder ankurbeln will wie glaubhaft ist
dass und wie sehr können wir uns auf
informationen aus china noch verlassen
ich denke das ist zunächst mal eine
festlegung und wir werden das sehen
werden zu beobachten können wir werden
das früher wissen als wir selber in ein
größeres problem reingehen wenn wir
jetzt natürlich ein paar verzögerungs
maßnahmen auch relativ schnell in kraft
setzen
und das wird dann auch wieder zur
einschätzung der gesamtsituation
beitragen
das hier ist keine influenza ist es ein
virus das kein mediziner in seiner
lebenszeit und auch nicht in
historischen aufzeichnungen
nachvollziehen kann in seinem verhalten
als pandemie
wir können uns nur begrenzt auf die
geschichtlichen erfahrungen mit
influenza pandemien verlassen denn das
ist wirklich ein anderes virus wo viele
grund parameter etwas anders sind und
dieses etwas anders sein
das bewirkt zum teil ganz große
unterschiede und auch jetzt zum beispiel
die gesamtdauer des geschehens ein
zuschauer ist man immer wieder gespannt
werden
es ist fast nicht möglich also man kann
sich dinge zurecht legen
man kann von bei einfachen feststellung
anfangen es werden sich wahrscheinlich
so 70% bevölkerung von der vorstellung
ist dass jeder zweite erwachsene
ungefähr kinder sind ja auch dabei die
werden sich infizieren müssen
das ist diese berühmte durchseuchung
jahren der mann genau aber die müssen ja
nicht auch sich alle dabei schwer krank
infizieren da zählen auch die unbemerkt
infizierten dazu also wir können sagen
diejenigen die eine immunreaktion zeigen
egal ob sie sich schwer oder ganz mild
oder unbemerkt
jetzt haben wie lange dauert das dieses
virus da da gibt es zunehmende daten
dazu das könnte sich etwas langsamer
verbreiten als influenza aber nur etwas
so eine influenza-pandemie die verläuft
häufig so in einem guten jahr oder
anderthalb jahren so dass man jetzt hier
auch denken könnte vielleicht ist es ein
gutes jahr oder bis zu zwei jahren ein
bisschen reserve gedacht und das wird
nicht konstant durchlaufen ich denke das
ist schon auch temperatur und saisonale
effekte gibt darum hoffe ich auch
weiterhin wenn wir jetzt stoppt
maßnahmen ergreifen das wird nicht zum
stillstand kommen aber vielleicht gibt
uns eben dieser temperatur effekt auch
ein rückenwind und wir kommen in eine
relativ sanft ansteigende kinetik da
rein und könnten dann durchaus zeit bis
nach dem sommer gewinnen und das ist
sehr sehr erstrebenswert das zu
versuchen und hätte dann wirklich auch
vorbereitungszeit also so in entlang
dieser linien denke ich da und noch mal
die frage nach den zahlen weil auch das
beschäftigt immer wieder sehr sehr viele
menschen in diesem land diese 60 bis 70
prozent die es treffen wird nun auch
zitiert von angela merkel aber in
allererster linie natürlich von ihnen
und jeden sechsten wird es schwer
treffen
das hochgerechnet hat professor villa
noch der chef des rk ii des
robert-koch-institutes gesagt oder wenn
es auch nur jeder siebte oder achte wäre
wären auch das noch unglaubliche zahlen
oder glauben sie dass die schwerste
erkrankungen tatsächlich eben in einem
geringer zu definierende bereich sind
das ist auch ganz schwer zu sagen
also erstmal ist die frage was ist denn
überhaupt schwer wenn sie meinen
intensivstation nein das ist nicht jeder
sechste das sind viel viel weniger also
ich kann hier jetzt auch nicht einfach
irgendeine zahl in die welt setzen
wir müssen uns aber schon klar machen da
stehen zum beispiel jetzt in den
schätzungen nach dem großen whu besuch
in china 5 prozent in den tabellen
das ist aber eine situation wo die
meisten die überwältigende mehrheit der
fälle aus johann com und das war ja ein
vollkommen überlastetes
gesundheitssystem und da kommt es zu
effekten die nicht linear sind und also
dass ein beispiel zum beispiel da kriegt
dann eben nicht jeder mehr ein intensiv
bett und dann sterben auch mehr als
eigentlich der fallzahl entsprechen
deswegen glaube ich dass wir da
eigentlich viel geringer liegen da sieht
man schon daran dass man außerhalb der
provinz hubei also das was woran um gibt
nur eine falsch nur eine fall
sterblichkeit von 0,7 prozent hatte in
china selbst nach offiziellen whu
missions- zahlen während das drei bis
vier prozent waren in doha und dubai
und das ist dasselbe virus dieselbe
bevölkerung dieselbe zeit nur eine
unterschiedliche infektions dichte und
da da sieht man schon
man kann das nicht so einfach umrechnen
und das sind zum teil auch zahlen
die muss man jetzt wirklich für sich
selber auch mal ein bisschen korrigieren
so so hoch werden die zahlen nicht
liegen dennoch wenn man dann weiter
rechnet zum beispiel wenn man jetzt
projizieren würde dass das eine große
fall häufung in drei monaten stattfindet
so was würde man in influenza wellen
erwarten
dann hätten wir trotzdem also wenn wir
nur mit zwei prozent intensivstation
aufenthalten rechnen hätten wir ein
problem mit unserer intensiv kapazität
es kann aber genauso gut sein dass diese
drei monate sich auf sechs oder neun
monate ausdehnen diese fallzahlen und
das sind wirklich und und dann ist es zu
verkraften
und das sind wirklich projektionen die
ich hier einfach so nicht machen kann
insofern kommt es auf das jetzt an und
einer war es schon richtig bescheid
donald trump nämlich der kennt auch den
schuldigen und der schuldige so sagt der
amerikanische präsident ist europa durch
unser frühes und entschlossenes handeln
ist die zahl der infektionsfälle in den
usa dramatisch geringer als jetzt in
europa die eu hat dabei versagt die
gleichen vorsichtsmaßnahmen zu ergreifen
und ein reifen aus china und anderen
hotspots zu verbieten
im ergebnis haben wir nun eine große
zahl neuer krone ausbrüche in den usa
verbreitet von reisenden aus europa um
zu verhindern dass weitere fälle über
unsere grenzen kommen verfügen wir ein
einreiseverbot für europäer in die
vereinigten staaten für die nächsten 30
tage ab freitag mitternacht gesperrt
europa aus was bedeutet das für die
deutsche wirtschaft also ich bin ja auch
gegen handelsbarrieren und gegen celle
und halte solche maßnahmen natürlich für
völlig widersinnig habe ich habe auch
betont wie wichtig ist dass wir in
europa solidarität haben dass sie auch
gerade grenzen offen halten und
natürlich geht es auch für den
transatlantischen dialog insofern und ob
es eine geeignete maßnahme ist europäer
auszusperren aber briten nicht das
werden die amerikaner entscheiden müssen
was wird es aktuell frauen halle für die
weltwirtschaft bedeuten ja das erschwert
natürlich die geschäftsbeziehungen die
er mitunter sehr wichtig sind mit den
usa als größter volkswirtschaft
es hat vor allem an der börse natürlich
der ganz grosse auswirkungen heute
gehabt das hat einfach bei uns an den an
den börsen noch mal so eine weitere
eskalationsstufe abgerufen und und in
den usa auf wo der handel ausgesetzt
werden musste weil
der dauer einfach viel zu stark
abgeschmiert ist also insofern wir
müssen sehen wie lange jetzt die grenzen
wirklich dicht bleiben zu den usa aber
es hat natürlich vor allem in erster
linie auch eine symbolische wirkung
gehabt
frau köhler die usa schotten sich ab für
menschen wie du dann kommt das böse
immer von außen und dann ist völlig klar
dass er versucht das virus auszusperren
ja da sieht man auch schon wieder die
metaphern kraft natürlich auch dieses
dieses begriffs oder überhaupt sozusagen
von so medizinischen vorgängen die ja
oft daneben tatsächlich auch für absolut
regressive oder auch reaktionäre
interessen letzten endes in anspruch
genommen werden und das kommt natürlich
bei donald trump kommt das eben auch
zusammen
auch die frage nochmal einem herrn
drosten wenn donald trump sagt wir haben
das virus ausgesperrt praktische frage
waren die europäer zu zögerlich mit
ihren einreise stopps also ist es gibt
da ja verschiedene schuhe ganz viele
interpretationsmöglichkeiten der
realität aber es gibt ein paar dinge die
wir wissen und wir wissen zum beispiel
dass es im ganzen januar viel mehr
einreisen in die usa gab als nach europa
und dann ist es natürlich auch so wir
wissen dass die vereinigten staaten die
die test häufigkeit viel geringer war
und das ist eigentlich das was uns hier
leitet also man muss sich ja schon mal
klar machen wenn wir nicht testen würden
dann würden wir in vielen ländern gar
nicht dass dieses virus überhaupt gibt
wird amerika haben dann würden so viel
zu spät angefangen und darüber will der
präsident jetzt hinwegtäuschen genau
also man kann sich da ein sondern eins
zusammenzählen und sich eigentlich
denken wahrscheinlich ist das virus in
den usa genauso verbreitet oder sogar
noch mehr als in europa auch unsere
nachbarn unter scholz entscheiden die
grenzen dicht zu machen wir haben das
schon in der runde wenigstens erwähnt
europa ist eigentlich im innern
grenzenlos ein wert an sich wird diese
epidemie möglicherweise auch das in
frage stellen nein das glaube ich nicht
und ich finde auch dass man eigentlich
an dem was seit trampler gemacht
wie grotesk das ist also seine ganze
politische ideologie beruht ja darauf
sich irgendwelche feinde zu suchen und
die dann heftig zu beschimpfen und
maßnahmen zu ergreifen
aber das ist alles im ideologischen
bereich nur hier
da ist der virus untrüglicher kann
dieses theater diesen firlefanz nicht
mehr glaubwürdig weiter durchführen und
deshalb wird auch die amerikanische
bevölkerung an dieser stelle damit nicht
umgehen können er ist ja ein heftigste
kritik geraten wegen dieser sache und
eigentlich ist das ganze politikmodell
trump an dieser frage und an dieser
entscheidung zusammengebrochen und auf
europa übersetzt heißt das nein wir
sollten die tatsache dass wir
zusammenhalten nutzen
das werden wir in der gemeinsamen
gesundheits bekämpfung gesundheits
stabilisierung machen müssen um die
krankheiten zu bekämpfen
aber es ist auch etwas das wir
wirtschaftlicher hinsicht unbedingt tun
müssen
ich werde anfang nächster woche im rat
der europäischen finanzminister in dem
rat der finanzminister des euros
zusammen kommen wir sind die ganze zeit
am sprechen miteinander telefonieren
über all diese fragen und ich habe mir
fest vorgenommen dafür zu sorgen dass
deutschland den beitrag leistet für den
zusammenhalt europas dass wir diese
krise sowohl medizinisch gut bewältigen
aber eben auch wirtschaftlich